I think there's a very real risk of a
war between United States and China
centered on Taiwan but not exclusively
about Taiwan in fact much more
consequential in the coming years and I
think the only way that China is going
to achieve its stated basically or
implicitly discernable goals of regional
hegemony over Asia the world's largest
market area essentially dominance of the
world's largest market area is I think
through military force and I'm happy to
unpack that and I think it's very
important for Market participants to
understand that because there's a
tendency to think that that's like so
too dramatic and doesn't really rack up
and it's not economically rational I
actually think that's not not
necessarily
true all right guys bang bang I've got
Elbridge here with me uh bridge I
thought a great place for us to get
started is all eyes on the current
events of the Ukraine Russia conflict
and now Hamas and Israel um how much of
our attention should be Focus there in
what I would consider kind of short-term
immediate conflict versus this long-term
trade-off which what appears China
playing this long-term game potentially
Taiwan being you know part of that
equation and in the United States almost
has this tension between short-term
versus long-term you seem to have a very
different opinion than most people on on
where we should be focused yeah well
thanks Anthony and great great to be
with you and your your listeners I think
you're I think you're right um I mean
look I think we should support our close
Ally Israel and I think you know we're
going to have to remain engaged in
Europe in some way but by far the most
significant challenge to American
interests I mean the first peer economy
in 150 years to the United States is
China uh if you measure it by market
exchange we're still quite a bit bigger
but if you use purchasing power parody
which is a better metric for
understanding you know military power
for instance China may already be larger
than we are they have for instance 200
times the ship building capacity and
that's according to the Office of Naval
intelligence so what's going on right
now um look I think it pays to be a
little bit um suspicious and maybe a
paranoid as Henry Kissinger said even
the paranoid have enemies honestly
what's looking to me like what's
happening is um
uh or what I would say is kuono who
benefits from the current situation well
I think you could make arguments about
Iran you can certainly make arguments
that Russia benefits by distracting
America tension away from Europe but
even more than Russia I think China
benefits why is that well I mean to kind
of get down to the point I think there's
a very real risk of a war between the
United States and China centered on
Taiwan but not exclusively about Taiwan
in fact much more consequential in the
coming years and I think the only way
that China is going to achieve its
stated basically or implicitly
discernable goals of regional hegemony
over Asia the world's largest market
area essentially dominance of the
world's largest market area is I think
through military force and I'm happy to
unpack that and I think it's very
important for Market participants to
understand that because there's a
tendency to think that that's like so
too dramatic and doesn't really rack up
and it's not economically rational I
actually think that's not not
necessarily true it's it's TBD but I
actually think the way that China is
behaving and and the statement is saying
and its military buildup are more
consistent with the behavior of
traditionally of rising great Powers
which seek to use military force to
achieve what I think of as a secure
geoeconomic sphere basically a very
large market area for their companies
their Industries to have scale which you
know matters as much now as it did a 100
years ago if that's the case and if it's
comes down to military power China
benefits enormously if the United States
is depleted and distracted in other
theaters and we've already depleted our
stock piles great deal aiding Ukraine
look Ukraine is a just cause it's a
self-defense against an evil aggression
but we have to look at things
realistically I mean the way I think
about our foreign policies it should be
thought of more as like a business uh
than a kind of a charity cause right and
so you have to think of it in a kind of
a fiduciary way and we're not prepared
to deal with the multi-front problem and
we've used a lot of our weapons a lot of
money a lot of political will in Ukraine
now we're going to be iMed potentially
in the crisis in the the Middle East
hopefully not directly involved I think
we should try to avoid that if at all
possible uh for for you know the reasons
I'm explaining here but the the biggest
shoe has yet to drop I mean the the you
know the size 14 compared to much
smaller shoes um which is the potential
for the Chinese to move and here's a
critical thing the Chinese are going to
give us as little warning as humanly
possible if they go in that direction
because if you're going to launch an
invasion against Taiwan and strike at
the Americans you don't want to give us
warning to flush our forces and disperse
them and make them more capable so I
think that's the real danger and you
know if I if I put the the points
together on a graph what's most
consistent is that China benefits I'm
not saying China plotted what Hamas is
doing but I'm saying I I I surmise I
infer that Hamas has read the room if
you will of not only Iran but Russia and
China saying this kind of thing is going
to be
welcomed when we look at this scenaria I
think there are a multitude of different
directions that we could kind of go in
uh you know we can talk about Russ R
Ukraine we can talk about Israel we can
talk about China we can talk about the
southern border we can talk about the
economics like there's so much to unpack
here but maybe what we could actually
dig in on to to kind of have people
understand what the end game would be
China actually invading Taiwan what does
that look like and what would the
potential us response be in that
scenario well I think the endgame is not
just taking over Taiwan people tend to
focus on on uh China's Ambitions about
Taiwan because it's considered a loss
Province because of the Chinese Civil
War and so forth and so on that is all
true but that's actually not the deepest
reality which is China basically needs
to take over Taiwan to be able to break
out of What's called the first island
chain formed by the Japanese archipelago
Taiwan itself and the Philippines so
that's been a barrier to Chinese or
Soviet power since the end of the second
world war that the United States has
held to so China needs to be able to do
that China needs to also if it's going
to achieve that secure geoeconomic
sphere that I was talking about uh which
they believe that we are trying to
constrain and strangle their future
Economic Development bear that in mind
that's what xinping himself is
indicating and that's certainly
consistent with their government
Behavior if China's going to do that it
needs to break apart this this
anti-hegemonic
Coalition that I think if that's not a
formal thing like an Asian NATO it's
rather a mental model of what's
happening with our alliance building um
in in Asia Japan India Philippines South
Korea Taiwan Australia Etc Vietnam um so
that's what's going on if China is going
to do that though it's going to go after
Taiwan because taian is the first step
and they have the strongest case because
they have a very wellestablished
political claim I'm not we don't
acknowledge it but most countries
recognize or kind of acknowledge Taiwan
as being part of China what's that going
to look like a lot of people say well
China will boil a frog they'll use
peaceful means they'll use so-called
disinformation I don't like that term
but that kind of thing well I actually
don't think that's what they're
ultimately GNA do in fact they've been
partially because they've been doing
that for the last 25 years and not only
has it not succeeded it's backfired
China is basically in like Taiwan has
moved farther and farther away from
China over time and is heading in the
direction of really a kind of a settled
status quo of of informal Independence
and even the possibility of formal
Independence which I certainly oppose
but we oppose as as a as a country so so
if you're in Beijing and you're thinking
well maybe Taiwan will one day you know
will convince the people on Taiwan to
vote to become part of the People's
Republic there's like zero chance of
that especially after what they sawen in
Hong Kong and how things are in the
mainland no no no okay Chinese can see
that if they see that what's their
option military force if you're going to
use military force well basically you're
going to do it right which means you're
not going to do probably do a blockade a
blockade can be part of an operation
problem with a blockade is it basically
forfeits the element of surprise I was
referring to before and forfeits your
ability to up the go up the escalation
ladder and say I'm going to solve this
problem and I think a big lesson I'm
sure I would bet a lot of money I'm not
sure but I would bet a lot of money to
Chinese are drawing from Russia's
experience in Ukraine is don't mess
around go big or go home and if you're
going to go big don't give a lot of
warning so but not only they probably
going to attack Taiwan but they are
going to have to attack US forces in the
region and probably Japanese as well
because they're not going to want to
leave themselves vulnerable which is
going to mean it's going to look
something more like December 1941 than
people probably appreciate now let's say
that uh they were able to uh
successfully invade Taiwan and
essentially establish some level of
control is the US response to then go
and try to take Taiwan back or is it
something where you know whoever gets
there first kind of you know is able to
put the flag on the ground and it's over
before it even started I think
unfortunately it's going to be very very
difficult to take Taiwan back if the
Chinese have secured control it's not
impossible in the sense that you could
over time cut off um uh you know China's
ability to for instance sustain its
forces on the island if you gained air
and sea control in the area around or at
least not necessarily control but
Advantage which would be extremely
difficult because the Chinese can
operate from their their Mainland
territory I think if Taiwan Falls this
is why that why I focus a lot like in my
book and in my work in the Pentagon on
on the so-call fet comp plea which is
just I mean I think most people are
familiar from with it from everyday life
but it's basically the strategy of
creating new facts on the ground before
people can get really mobilized and
that's in military terms but it's can be
a business strategy it can be in in a
lot of different walks of life um uh and
then and then kind of basically
convincing him it's not worth uh going
to the cost and risk of reversing it so
I think if Taiwan Falls we may we may
get to that point unfortunately I
increasingly am afraid that our lack of
preparedness and urgency taiwan's own
lack of preparedness and urgency Japan's
slow pace are leading to a situation in
which it may become untenable it's not
impossible to defend Taiwan which but
that the the key thing here Anthony is
that the situation is going to be more
grave and Urgent and extreme what if
that happens why because China's goals
are not merely limited to unification
with Taiwan I mean they're talking about
becoming the globally preeminent country
and da da da da da and I think it's a
pretty reason very reasonable influence
to suggest their Ambitions go far far
beyond for instance their military force
development clearly envisions using
military forces well beyond Taiwan and
that's a very costly signal of what
their future intent is likely to look
like and so in that case I think we're
going to have to like double triple down
on Asia because in that context people
in like Japan the Philippines and Hanoi
Australia are going to say wait a minute
I was prepared to stick my neck out to
work with the Americans to balance China
because I thought it was prudent I
thought they were the big dog but now it
looks like China's actually the big dog
maybe I'd better cut a deal and that's
going to be that's human nature it's
only rational and that's going to be a
very very difficult thing to push
against in that context so that's a lot
of the urgency is why I'm trying to say
look let's not let I mean I know this is
more commercial audience but in the
policy world I'm really saying we got to
focus on Taiwan because if we lose it
it's only going to get worse I think
implicitly in a lot of people's mind
there's an idea that if Taiwan Falls the
Chinese will kind of stop there and I
just don't think that comports with
either their behavior or human
nature what is the impact of something
like that on financial markets on global
trade you know obviously people focus
very much on the superconductors and
tsmc but but there's obviously other
impact as well how do you think about
okay if China was successful here
how does America respond from an
economic standpoint and and what would
investors need to be paying attention to
today's episode is brought to you by
trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you it's the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trustand will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trust and will
/om I think it has enormous
ramifications for commercial people of
all kinds and I think people um I think
the semiconductor issue is helpful in
kind of loc in in in
concretizing that but it's it's Way
Beyond semiconductors just to be clear I
would not defend Taiwan just for
semiconductors like better to Offshore
and figure it out and maybe go on rather
than risk World War III the problem is
it's much more than that because I think
again going back to what does China
really want and what Rising great Powers
tend to want is that secure GE
geoeconomic sphere what does that mean
for Market actors it means the center of
the economic world is no longer the
United States it's no longer New York
City and Silicon Valley and Regulators
in Washington it's China it's Beijing
it's Shanghai it's Wuhan it's gujo
whatever you know that is that is the
it's Hong Kong that is the future that
China wants why not why wouldn't they
want that that's pretty awesome then you
have you know basically your regul your
standards become common your companies
get favored in commercial uh flows you
get the scale advantages of selling to
the world's largest market you get to
use sanctions I mean we go around and we
throw sanctions on Swiss banks and yada
yada yada and they have to they have to
fall in wine why because you can't
afford to get blocked out of the
American Market or or be prevented from
using the dollar that's the future I
think the Chinese are ultimately trying
to supplant us from and if they seize
Taiwan that's a major step it's not the
end of the story I don't think but it's
the story is going to be a lot sadder
and more difficult at that point but
that's the future that and I think you
can basically see that because people
talk about decoupling like the Chinese
are already trying to decouple from us
and they're trying to create a parallel
economy they're trying to basic you know
I mean we're starting to see
dollarization I know there's a lot of
debate about the dollar and exactly you
know the downsides of the Chinese to
using Reserve currency now okay fine but
the point is over the long period of
time I think that's the world they want
to create if you're a market actor and
you're assuming that alphabet and apple
and meta are going to be the biggest
companies in the world if China's
dominant over Asia I don't think think
that's true anymore because Chinese
companies become the dominant one
because they get pref preference in say
selling into the oan market right which
is going to be the world's largest areas
of growth is is is the Asian markets
potentially you know India Japan Etc
right and the Chinese will will use that
to disfavor our companies and to shrink
us and then ultimately they may become
subsidiaries of of those Chinese
companies and so that's the future this
ultimately and this is one of the
reasons I I really uh try to reach out
to the commercial Community is
ultimately the stakes here are economic
but the means that China would use to
pursue that goal are substantially
military in nature if I was to have this
conversation with you five years ago I
think that the uh kind of Economic and
investment Community would tell you
invest in China it's fast growing it has
all this opportunity you know get on the
trend of growth and uh the returns will
follow in the last couple of months it
seems like there's data coming out that
growth is actually not as fast or as big
as uh previously thought uh there has
been a number of issues in the debt
markets and the real estate markets
there's been collaps of very large
companies there have been uh Executives
who have been you know either surveilled
or kind of Taken under control of the
CCP Etc how do you think about China's
kind of economic you know positioning
today versus maybe what the promise or
or the thought process was you know
three to five years ago well look it's
interesting I mean from a strategic
point of view I think we have to it's
almost like not reached that ISS in the
sense that I think we have to prepare
for the downside risk from a strategic
point of view of continued Chinese
growth so like I don't I don't make
predictions um that said you know kind
of from a market point of view and just
kind of getting into a leaning forward a
little bit on the issue I personally
think that China is not about to fall
apart I don't see the evidence for that
I see China slowing down I mean I see
them you know probably meeting the
frontier in some areas they've got
structural issues with misallocation of
capital and so forth but on the other
hand you know there's an enormous and in
substantial
uh extent untapped human capital
potential in China That's not at the
frontier I mean maybe in Shanghai
they're at the frontier but like this is
not Japan this is not a country that you
know in 1991 was at like top oecd levels
so they have a lot of head room for
growth and frankly some of what they're
doing I mean the fact that they're not
doubling down on the property sector and
I'm not an expert on this might actually
be good because it would just like
inflate the problem further um so and
and the other thing is I tend to be a
bit more dovish on economic measures so
again this is stems the ultimate Stakes
what what we in China are ultimately in
rivalry about is money is because money
is what makes the world go around but
also it's what creates geopolitical and
military strength but at the end of the
day as ma dong put it power comes out of
the barrel of a gun right so the guy
with the gun will dominate the guy with
the dollar now you need you need the
dollar to get the gun but at the end of
the day right and so because I don't
that's linked my sense and this not just
because I focus on this issue I've
become increasingly convinced of this
the gun is dominant because economic
sanctions don't coers people very well
it's very difficult to use money to
basically get people to do things that
they really don't want to do you know
you can induce people to do things on
the margin that they don't want to do
maybe kind of nudge them but our
experience with sanctions including
against the Russians is they really
don't work so that's true of the Chinese
but it's also true of us so what that
means is I'm not as worried about
building up economic sanctions because I
actually don't think it's going to coers
China like if China invades Taiwan and
conquers Taiwan first of all I'm very
skeptical that we would put massive
sanctions on them because it would it
would like potentially blow up our own
economy but secondly I don't think it
would coer the Chinese anyway and by the
way I don't think the Europeans and the
middle easterners and the Latins would
go let alone the Russians would go along
with it but what that means is that
means I'm actually less I put less
pressure on decoupling now I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm um receptive or supportive of
decoupling for our own reasons on our
own terms but that's different than
saying it's necessary for our strategy
so what I would say for a market point
of view is if you think you can I mean I
basically I focus on don't contribute to
the Chinese military buildup and we need
to decouple on things that we really
can't afford the Chinese to be able to
like have a strangle hook
Pharmaceuticals you know semiconductors
Etc okay so that's a relatively narrow
set of things otherwise from my point of
view from a strategic point of view
people can go in there your point taken
that there's more risk there just in
terms of how the Chinese economy is
doing but I would just be you know my
advice is to say look that's me I'm a
kind of a realist I try to look at
things dispassionately but if we get
into a war with China which is very
possible and tens of thousands possibly
more Americans are getting killed how
much do you want your business plan and
your investment you know future to rely
on China I mean I would put a heavy
discount on that so if there's something
really lucrative or shortterm that's not
going to get you Crosswire that's one
thing but if there's you know if you're
hoping that just things are going to be
fine I really don't think that's a very
prudent investment so you were very very
uh involved in creating some of the
changes in what I'll call our defense or
geopolitical strategy um what is your
evaluation of America's Readiness uh
both as a government from a strategic
standpoint but also from a war fighting
capability standpoint if we were 100%
focused on being able to address this
issue so if we didn't have uh Ukraine
and Russia we didn't have Hamas and
Israel how ready are we for this at the
current moment we're not as far as I can
tell I mean it's all relative and it's a
matter of degree but you know in a
conventional War um you know the old
expression for one of a shoe the kingdom
was lost you can have outsized effects
because of relatively marginal
advantages in uh capability or position
or other things so you know the example
of actually the Anglo front I mean the
French army was considered the best
military in Europe in 1940 but the
Germans proved to be better they
actually had fewer I believe they had a
smaller number of troops at least total
mobilized for the offensive in the
Battle of France I'm not exactly sure
but but basically they were able to
break through in some key areas in uh
the Battle of I think around sedan and
then Crossing some of the rivers in
northern France and that led to a
collapse in the Anglo French position um
with with enormous strategic
consequences that that are far greater
than like the narrow issue of the battle
and so that's that's very important and
that's what really I think our strategy
we kind of know what for instance the
Biden administration's defense strategy
is quite similar from what I understand
to our strategy defense strategy in the
Trump Administration that really shifted
us to focus on China and War fighting
Readiness for deterrence so I don't I
don't think we don't have like a
strategy problem at this point I mean we
do have a strategy problem in the sense
that like we need to really really focus
but like what we're saying on the on
words on the paper is not the big
problem the big problem is the level of
of effort and concentration and that's
what sort of a big part of what I'm
doing now is it's less like very
theoretical stuff and more like like
focus focus focus because you know you
said something interesting Anthony which
is you know if Hamas weren't a problem
if Ukraine weren't a problem I don't
think we can wait for these areas to be
settled to be stable because it probably
is never going to happen and also that
obviously leads to an incentive which is
probably what's happening right now to
go to your original question that
Beijing and Moscow are trying to use
configration in these regions to tie us
down and deplete Us in the in what for
China is the central theater and of
course China is the key actor Russia
wouldn't be able to support this war
effort if its economy weren't being
propped up by Beijing by China so I
think this is the issue and I mean you
know one of the things that drives me
crazy I mean President Biden and I this
is true of of many Republicans too this
is not a partisan comment but President
Biden said um you know in mid- October
on 60 Minutes that you know we're
America we can do all these things we
can support Israel and Ukraine and
everything else and I was thinking to
myself like you and what army I mean if
you look at the budget I mean our
defense spending is historic low and I'm
not saying that it's realistic to expect
us to dramatically increase defense
spending in these contexts but very
Little's been done to fundamentally
change our defense industrial base our
allies are moving slowly if it all with
a couple of exceptions like Poland um to
some extent Japan Australia um so like
the accounts are not adding up and I
always to go back to my point about
running things like a business what
business is successful I mean I'm not a
business you know I've never run a
business but like I thought it was
pretty standard management practice that
you pick a priority and you make sure
that that's what you hit maybe you have
maybe you have two or three priorities
Max but you really make sure you hit
those things and you do it right and you
don't you don't take ma major risk and
that's what's basically happening is
we're doing good things in Asia but it's
more like moving let's say let's call it
like a 30 Dee angle meantime China's
military buildup IS up like this I don't
know what that would be like an 80
degree angle and so it's like you know
you know it's like if if you're if you
know if you're a Salesman in a company
and and you say hey hey boss I doubled
my my sales from last year but your boss
says well your
competitor uh is doing 10x that's that
you're not doing well enough because
it's all relative and that's the
fundamental problem and especially when
you when I think that shiin ping and
Beijing have a lot of reasons for
movement in this decade if not sooner I
don't make predictions I don't know
what's in Shan Ping's head but they're
actively exercising their military and
trying to fix problems that they know
they have there's reason for them to
think that if they wait around too long
the American Military and and the
Japanese and Taiwanese military will get
a lot stronger xiin ping himself who has
elevated the Taiwan issue a lot is not
Immortal he's a Marxist so like that's a
given and they can see this Coalition
forming around them so they they appear
to me to be behaving like a country
that's getting ready to try to deliver
us a knockout blow again I don't know I
don't know but I mean my basic view is
anybody who says he or she does know is
not very credible because nobody should
claim to know because Shin Ping's not
sharing that information with anybody
and if he is we're not sure he's telling
us the
truth now how do private companies like
andil and others that appear to uh one
take a different approach to kind of
building out some of this
military-industrial base uh two seem to
be doing it with a very heavy bent
towards technology and Innovation and
kind of what I would consider like the
modern Battlefield um is that enough to
help us like do we just need 10 more
Ander rils and you know we'll be in a
much better place and and we'll be good
to go or is this something that we're
going to need public and private sector
both working together along with
politicians and getting funding and like
like how complex and and like systems
level is it versus hey we just need you
know two more Palmer luies and like
we'll be good to get that's a really
good question Anthony and I I should say
I mean I have a lot of friends at Ander
roll and admire a lot of what they're
doing but I think we're going to need
systemic change um that's probably going
to involve frankly and I don't have I'm
thinking trying to think through this I
mean one of the critiques I get is like
Bridge you say we need to revamp and
overhaul our defense industrial base but
what do you mean and my response is kind
of like well I I mean we're a two person
organization I don't have like 50
analysts working under me um I think the
main thing is there are plenty of people
who could do that if we get the
political will to dive into that problem
others are going to be better equipped
than I to come up with it so but I'm
trying to I'm trying to get a better
answer to that this is I mean I've been
calling for a national mobilization of
our defense industrial base for over a
year at this point since it became clear
that with the Ukraine war that we were
going to heavily deplete our stockpiles
and that things were going to go south
probably in other places as well um the
reason I think that we're going to need
more like a National Enterprise level I
think that's a good way of of of putting
it in that in that kind of Commercial
Way is because um these are not minor
changes that we're going to need what
we're seeing in Ukraine I think very
vividly is drones are going to be really
important AI is going to be really
important new networking is going to be
really important but actually the
battlefield in Ukraine probably wouldn't
be that infamiliar to a soldier fighting
on the Western Front in early
1918 I mean the drones and that's
largely because both sides are
exploiting technology and a lot of It
ultimately and so they often tend to
cancel each other out or or they adapt
to each other and so what becomes really
important are numbers attrition and uh
the way you employ the force and then
the advantages of position and resolve
and so forth so it's like it's more
oldfashioned and that
world Legacy platforms as they're called
can be very useful um it depends on how
they're how they're fitted together in
what's called Force employment but what
this says to me is we're going to need
to be able to you know look if if if we
and the Chinese get in battle and we
both sink each other or whatever we're
going to need to be able to produce as
much as we did and the thing that
worries me about this is I think a lot
of us even though we know there's been
de-industrialization over the last
generation we sort of have in our mind
that we can always pull a World War II
here's the scary thing in some ways we
are more like the Japanese and China's
more like America in 1941 why do I say
that and I'm say I mean I'm saying it
for eff a bit it's not a Perfect Analogy
because Japan was 10% our economic size
and we're a peer of China but Japan in
1941 had an Exquisite standing military
it had some of the best neor aviators in
the world an incredible Navy submarines
they figured out how to work Torpedoes
in Shallow Pearl Harbor very the zeros
like schooled us all over the Pacific
for the first six months to a
year here's the problem we basically
killed all those people they killed a
lot of our people but then we had the
world's largest industrial base so we
produced a 100 more aircraft carriers
and we produced thousands of aircraft
and other ships and submarines and
Torpedoes and bombs and blah blah blah
and we just overwhelmed them and
unfortunately that's a little bit how
the situation is with us we have an
incredible standing military although
sometimes I worry that not so much the
war Fighters themselves but the rest of
us take it for granted in terms of hubis
but China's the one with an enormous
industrial capacity I mean I was struck
this is the off Office of Naval
intelligence officially using open
sources calculated the Chinese have 200
times I believe the the ship building
capacity we do and now uh you know
Senator Dan suvin on the on the floor
the Senate said recently that that the
intelligence community estimates that
China may be actually spending roughly
equivalent to US depend if you kind of
net it out so this is the real um this
is the real problem I think what we're
going to need is probably more direct
government intervention maybe even
taking over certain parts of the
functions making very clear to
contractors Etc I think we're going to
have to wave a lot of the regulations
environmental labor whatever to get the
kind of Workforce we need train it up
heavy investment upfront the thing I
would say is that I mean I obviously the
National Security Hawks are going to
like this but I also think a lot of the
people who want to reindustrialize our
country should like this too and you
can't do that without an upfront
investment and we have a compelling
National need there's going to be a
buyer not only ourselves but if we can
if we can churn out stuff like we used
to we had 30 defense primes in in the
1980s then we can supply Israel then we
can supply Ukraine to our hearts content
then we can supply Taiwan then we can
supply Japan South Korea Etc and that's
great and then we don't have to fight
all Wars you know for instance Israel
right now I hope not but they may end up
needing something like the airlift that
we delivered in 1973 197 was after
Vietnam we had no problem doing that
because we had a huge and healthy
industrial Base today it's going to be
tougher especially given that we've
given all these weapons to Ukraine so
when we think about the current
conflicts that are uh transpiring in
Ukraine and Israel um one of the aspects
that I think people they intuitively
kind of feel but they they can't wrap
their head around is the impact on the
national debt and kind of the economic
strength of America and so for example
um in the last month or so we have seen
the national debt grow by over $500
billion we're now over $ 33.5 trillion
of national debt and I think that there
is a path here and it's a possible path
not a guaranteed one uh where we
continue to fund uh both through direct
monetary contribution but also Weaponry
Etc uh the war in Ukraine we then get
involved with Israel and Hamas um and
maybe there's even a world where you
know with China Taiwan and kind of some
of the stuff we were talking about
there's more need for weapons and
monetary support Etc now Janet Yellen uh
treasury secretary was recently
interviewed and she said don't worry
about it we can afford to fund two Wars
um how should we think about the
pressures of the US economic strength
and the national debt as it either
reinforces or contradicts our
geopolitical strategy like are these
people thinking about hey what is the
impact on the national debt and on our
economic strength or are these two
completely separate worlds and they're
not even aware of each other to some
degree this episode is brought to you by
aradon they are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised $81 million to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultanously from blockchain to
artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin miner powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these aircooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on Dem man response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a r a d ne.com go check
them out at rod.com
today well um I was very disturbed by
yellen's comments which and and there's
a sort of Blas attitude towards the
situation that really worries me I am
not an economist
I am a person who believes there's no
free lunch in life you know I mean if
the kind of core of being a realist at
some level is like there you're going to
pay somehow and the notion that we can
borrow you know just enormous amounts of
money including in peace time without
there ultimately being some
feedback again I'm not a just doesn't
strike me as credible that that's going
to show somehow and my understanding and
you and your listeners would be better
equipped to comment on this than I but
like my understanding is interest rates
are starting to creep up and there are
indications in the bond market as well I
know the journal's been reporting I mean
Greg I had a column uh a week or two ago
pointing this out that there are early
warning signs and it's like well you
know you spend a few trillion here and
there on coid Aid and like other things
and you run huge deficits it's going to
start to pay up and I mean I I guess and
this is somebody pointing this out
Yellen I guess ignored this but like
interest on the debt is now going to
exceed in the coming years our defense
budget I think it's even going to exceed
like Social Security payments and it's
it's only going north right or South I
guess it's going not going in a good
direction um and so I just that that has
to matter and I mean one of the things
that I think is important I mean this is
more of a policy issue but I think it it
it ramifies to everybody is there's a
tendency like look I'm a big fan in a
lot of ways the Wall Street Journal oped
page but um and I've written there over
the years but the journal oped page page
will say these days that um there's no
trade-off it's a false choice we can do
all of this stuff but you know this is
the same Journal of B page that's
warning us about the consequences of
massive borrowing right I mean there was
a very interesting oped by I think
George W I think it was Glenn hubber
George W bush is one of his economic
guys saying we cannot afford to borrow
anymore and we can't raise taxes and I I
I don't know on the margin but that's I
mean you basically raising defense
spending is going to be painful and I
mean I think it's very obvious that
large numbers of people people don't
want to cut Social Security and Medicare
um and I mean both President Biden and
president Trump are opposed to it I saw
in the journal I think yesterday or
today that our Health Care system or
retirement system is ranked low in the
oecd and you know I don't I don't know
what the right answer is but what it
what it says to me is like it we not
just going to spend our way out and when
people compare our situation we just
need Ronald Reagan look I'm a big Ronald
Reagan fan but Ronald Reagan was coming
in and things were pretty bad in those
days but like much lower levels of debt
you know
I think a considerably probably better
economic and demographic profile in
terms of Youth and so forth um a lot
more in in in a stronger industrial base
and so forth so um I I I think that is a
really a very very serious issue and I
think there needs to be more attention
to it I do think we're going to have to
spend more on defense and do the things
kind of things on our defense industrial
base but the first thing is like if you
have a drinking problem is Step One is
acknowledge your problem right and so
when Janet yellen's out there being ah
no problem that that's like that's what
really worries me you got somebody who's
like up at coming in home at three at
night completely boted and like oh I
don't have a drink of BR like that's
that's when you really know that that
person has got trouble and that's and
that's going to affect uh affect all of
us we've been talking a lot about
conflicts elsewhere um if you look at
the rhetoric that is being used given
the southern border uh Trump building a
wall Biden not so interested it seems
like in doing so um there is talk that
you know we have this migrant crisis all
the way to the Other Extreme end would
describe it as an invasion um how does
the southern border and the influx of
people who are coming into the country
play into what we're talking around
geopolitics and kind of again economic
strain I think you know it's kind of how
I think about it yeah how does that play
into this that's a great question I mean
look I you know cards on the table I
think we should have a secure Southern
border I support a wall like I think we
should be able to secure our border and
decide who comes in and I generally am
in favor of less immigration I would
want more skilled immigration we could
move towards something like what the
Australians in have for instance that
would make more sense to me I mean look
we're at we're at unprecedentedly high
levels of a foreign born population I
think maybe in around the turn of the
century last century there was this two
centuries ago there was this level but
like you know that's when the
assimilation process needs to needs to
take some time and space um on the other
hand we do need like skilled workers and
so forth and I'm not an expert on
immigration but I think that kind of
model but I I just don't really
understand why we want wouldn't want to
have control of our Southern border like
that just seems and I think you know
first second of all like fentanyl is a I
mean it's killing 100,000 Americans a
year now it's not like I mean they have
some agency but like it's a horribly
addictive and lethal drug um and if we
can
try to stem that flow a bit we should do
so that is a national security issue if
it's killing 100,000 Americans a year
like we should be trying to so so that's
like that should be a priority now that
that doesn't necessarily trade off
against our other interests but it's
something that we should treat seriously
and with respect and more than respect
we should really do something about it
now part of that's treatment part of
that's dealing with the Mexicans and
blocking the Chinese and the Border it's
a multi-prong thing but I you know
that's something I've been trying to
think through a little bit more thinking
about the defense and security elements
of it but I think it's something we
should be doing I think more deeply
Anthony I think there's this sense that
a lot of Americans you know I'm a
republican I think particularly kind of
you know a lot of the the new right if
you will people who are against the
establishment I'm sympathetic to that I
mean there you always have an
establishment but I don't think our
establishment in the last generation did
a very good job I mean we had two failed
wars in the Middle East you had a
financial crisis and
de-industrialization of the American
economy and now we're in a situation
where China might beat us in a war how
did we get from from 2000 balanced
budget
unparalleled uh strength in the global
economy pretty healthy economy low crime
pretty good I remember we're probably
around the same age I remember September
200 and or no summer of 2001 the biggest
issues I can remember in the news were
this poor Shandra Levy who was killed in
in Rock Creek Park in Washington DC
shark attacks like an N Tucket and um
stem cells those are the problems we had
then and now we've got a lot bigger
problem problem so I think people are
justly dissatisfied with what our
established Powers have done over the
less um and I think part of that is on
the border people feel that there isn't
a seriousness about addressing this
issue especially border states but
throughout the country where it's like
hey this is a huge issue and it's being
imposed on us and um and that's why like
the the the Ukraine it's not logically a
tradeoff against Ukraine but people can
see that Washington DC and the areas and
and these kinds of things they're very
concerned about Ukraine and they can see
that those areas are not very concerned
about the border and so I think that's
where that linkage kind of comes from is
to say hey why don't you take my concern
seriously and um you know so so you know
that that's sort of my approach to that
that set of
issues when we see China kind of playing
this out obviously uh if you study China
for five minutes you know that they have
these very very long time Horizons
they're very patient um if I had to sum
up the concern I have it would be that
China will allow the United States to
bleed themselves dry and its Death By A
Thousand Cuts is that a good summary of
kind of where you know what what we're
facing and what we need to kind of be
vigilant against playing into yeah I I
think exactly I mean the Chinese are not
look I mean they're not like
um super strategist like they're so much
better than we are they're not like
they're human beings they make mistakes
but I do I agree with you that they tend
to have a long a longer term orientation
and be sort of more eye and Target and
ruthless part of that is I think because
we have gotten hubristic over the last
generation where we just like what Biden
said we're America whatever whereas the
Chinese actually come from a place of
humiliation and they've like
really struggled to get up the ladder I
mean a lot of their wounds were
self-inflicted by m for instance but um
but they they you know it's sort of the
it's the attitude of the guy who's
coming at like come up the hard way and
knows what it what it entailed and we're
sort of like the the guys's had you know
been on top for for his whole life sort
of thing or for as long as anyone can
remember um the only the only difference
I'd have with the death of a Thousand
Cuts I think there's a Thousand Cuts
then there's the knockout
blow they're they're I think what
they're doing is I don't know I mean
it's not an exact analogy but what was
Muhammad Ali's thing against you know I
mean it's not that's actually not a good
analogy but it's basically like wearing
us down wearing us down dulling us get
you know we're kind of tired we're
distracted and then boom The Knockout
blow because that's the only way you're
going to do it I don't think we're in a
thousand I don't think a Thousand Cuts
alone is going to do it and that's what
they're preparing they're preparing
their military for a knockout blow now
one other question I have is uh maybe
like the quality and dependability of
our intelligence um and and I'll give
you a couple of examples and and part of
why I'm interested in asking you is I
believe that you sat on the Iraqi wmd
commission I worked full time and so
just like like you've seen kind of the
The Good the Bad and and kind of all the
intricacies and and all this stuff right
and so um the attack by Hamas in Israel
I think there's a lot of people saying
like how did all of these intelligence
agencies miss it at the same time uh if
I think back to Russia Ukraine there was
you know half the people saying they're
not going to do it there was half people
saying they were going to do it um we
and we were saying that they were going
to lose remember that we take a lot of
credit now but we got that part wrong so
anyway go ahead well and and I think
that now we have all these amazing
Technologies right there there satellite
imagery and like like all these things
that we like oh this is
amazing how do you look at maybe our
ability to provide and capture this
intelligence that actually gives our
leaders the information they need to
make good decisions like if you have bad
information right you're GNA make bad
decisions and so where do you think we
are on that front sure so my general
View and I wrote about this I mean 15 20
years ago now uh people want to go back
and see I mean I tend to actually be
more lenient on the intelligence
function because yes of course yes they
make mistakes but bear in mind what we
ask intelligence to do is it's not like
hey you know who's going to win the you
know the Super Bowl it's like what is
like inherently uncertain problems that
are that are where where an adversary
with an incentive to dissemble and
dissimulate and deceive is going is is
operating and how how they might behave
towards us and the thing that I think um
and so S surprise or at least not
complete surprise but what I would think
of as like operational level surprise is
sort of endemic in the system in the
same way that probably in markets it's
like you know there was plenty of
information in 2008 you know but like it
was people weren't acting based on the
warnings right that's really the problem
or so so Israel probably picked up a lot
of the indicators that in retrospect
can be put together and this is even
going back to Pearl Harbor the signals
and noise issue is um you know look
technology doesn't solve everything
because the enemy knows that we have
these Technologies and then they act
accordingly so for instance Hamas
apparently from what I read and I mean
surmising they weren't using phones or
they may have spoken on phones that they
thought would be tapped in ways that
could deceive the Israelis because
they're not they're smart unfortunately
and similarly with like you know with
China I think
what we need to worry about and this is
important for Market actors if people
are thinking like oh I'm going to have a
lot of warning if China moves towards an
invasion of Taiwan uhuh because what
they're going to do in fact they've
already been doing this they're trying
to normalize and essentially hide in
plain sight so they're creating they're
making it hard for us to distinguish
what's like a real indicator from what's
it just noise and I mean if you go back
it's a little bit it's getting along it
was 50 years ago unfortunately now
there's the anniversary um is the Y War
but you know the yapur war was a war
that happened the attack began we
already had satellite imagery we already
had the ability to listen in on you know
Arab Egyptian and Syrian Communications
and so forth presumably but we were
still surprised why well because
partially because the Egyptians did a
bunch of exercises and then didn't
attack and so the Israelis said nah
they're just doing another exercise and
we believe them you know we went kind of
along with them as I understand I'm sure
we had a similar view but that's the
kind of problem where where surprise is
still and so I don't think we ever get
because the enemy is adaptive and your
adversary is adaptive and if they're
weaker they're going to adapt in certain
ways if they're stronger they're going
to adapt in other ways Etc depending on
what their goal is I think we should
assume that intelligence is always going
to be an imperfect really more of like
an art probably than a science uh
because of these inherent challenges
that it
faces my last question for you is um if
you had to pick one or two actionable
things that the United States could do
in the next you you know 90 to 120 days
what do you think would be the two most
impactful things that we could do to
better uh address the China issue but
also kind of improve our standing on the
global uh stage in terms of some of
these conflicts so what I it's funny you
mention that I've been thinking about
that recently and the answer I give is
actually pretty much what you say
because a lot of this again if we get
back to it's about the military balance
and it's about for want of a shoe the
kingdom was lost it's very hard for me
from the
outside that's a sort of a technical
military question a lot of it gets into
classified information I don't really
have access to or I don't have access to
so what I would say is if I were
empowered or I were advising you know
the king for a day or for a year or a
couple years I would say I want to
answer the question that you just asked
what are the things that I can do now I
can do right now going forward that will
help make sure that I can defeat a
Chinese invasion of Taiwan today
tomorrow six months a year 5 years 10
years and I want to do all those things
and I'm going to empower the people who
genuinely bring me Solutions I'm going
to sideline or even fire and make
examples of people who slow roll that I
mean I'm just not to name Nam but
there's this guy Frank McKenzie former
Central Command Commander big guy who
was trying to undermine this approach
who's now out in the public talking
about how we need to get back in the
Middle East that's the kind of person I
would say no that's not what we need I'm
going to reward people and I'm gonna do
we need to call do I need to call the
president to wave to say activate the
defense production act uh wave
regulations on the environment on labor
on blah blah blah blah whatever you know
uh the federal code I'm just we need to
get this done like yesterday and I'm not
going to let it stand in the way and
that is sort of that is what I would do
and I think that kind of
urgency um and and and credible signal
of priority because I think a lot of
what's going on right now is people see
the gums flapping that they don't really
believe that that's the priority what's
the priority Ukraine was the priority if
you solve the Ukraine problem you got
Kudos you know and now maybe if you're
helping on the Israel problem that's how
you get kudos and so it's constantly
going to the back of back of the line
and again who benefits China so that
that would be my um that would be the
way that I would go I I I continue to
believe we are pressing our luck but I
continue to believe that um we can deter
a Chinese attack because if they think
they are going to fail I don't think
they're going to do it bear in mind that
Maad dong never attacked
Taiwan despite wanting to because he
knew he would fail so I I believe it's
possible but we are really pressing our
luck and the hour is extremely
late where can we send people to find
you online or find the book sure well
thanks a lot I mean the book is called
the strategy of denial American defense
in an age of great power conflict it
came out two years ago but actually I
was talking to my editor earlier today I
think it's actually more relevant now
than it was then um so I think hopefully
of interest you can find on Amazon or at
Yale University press I'm on Twitter or
X at um elbd Colby my name and then uh I
my partner and I run a a nonprofit focus
on great power competition called the
marathon initiative I have all my
appearances and everything there
articles I published Etc if people are
haven't had enough if they want some
more they can go there Bri I really
appreciate it I'm uh uh thinking a lot
about this right now I think many people
are and so your perspective is not only
I think enlightening and kind of
informative but also um that there's an
element of positivity and optimism of
like hey it the story is not over yet
right there is still things that we can
do which which I think is important as
well so I appreciate your time and we'll
definitely do it again in the future
would welcome that Anthony thanks a lot